im unterfränkischen Alzenau arbeiten Sie
an einer technischen Revolution weil es
eben kunststoffbasierte Materialien sind
die wir verwenden wird es eine sehr
kosteneffiziente Lösung sein sie wollen
das Speichern von Strom aus Wind und
Sonne nachhaltig anders machen wir haben
jetzt innerhalb kürzester Zeit diese
Batterie entwickelt einen Beitrag
leisten um Deutschlands Energiewende zum
Erfolg zu führen
ohne große Energiespeicher kein gelegene
Energiewende
das Ziel mit organischen
Flüssigkeitsstrom speichern die
Energiewende unterstützen kombiniert und
verbindet man diese großbatterien können
Sie strohmmengen speichern die der
Leistungskapazität eines deutschen
Kohlekraftwerks entspricht wir verstehen
unser Produkt als Endprodukt als eine
Art Warenhaus für Strom das bedeutet Sie
haben zum Beispiel 200 300 400 MB
Stunden Energie die Sie einspeichern
können wenn sie verfügbar ist und die
sie dann ausspeichern können wenn Sie es
brauchen
160 Frauen und Männer arbeiten bei C im
Blue allein 100 in der Forschung um die
Batterien immer leistungsfähiger zu
machen flüssige Stromspeicher die Idee
hatte er Peter geigner Wasser als
Transportmittel für elektrische Energie
das Funktionieren des menschlichen
Körpers als Vorbild
2011 hat niemand an großer
Energiespeicher gedacht die größte
energiespeiche die zu der Zeit gab waren
Batterien die im Zweiten Weltkrieg in
U-Boote eingebaut worden sind danach hat
man sich damit nicht mehr wirklich
auseinandergesetzt aber uns war völlig
klar diese Fragestellung wird kommen und
sie ist heute da sie ist sie ist extrem
da seitdem haben sie gut 100 Millionen
Euro investiert dabei die Politik und
ihre Fördergelder bewusst außen vor
gelassen man wollte unabhängig zügig und
ohne staatliche Einmischung forschen
können wenn man schnell voranschreitet
dann ist man natürlich Politik
Bürokratie der das kostet alles Zeit und
wenn man diese Zeit nicht investieren
möchte dann muss man selber ein bisschen
investieren und diese Lösung haben wir
haben wir bevorzugt und ich glaube wir
sind sehr gut damit gefahren
deutsche Energiepolitik seit jeher
spannungsgeladen
1955 nach britischen Vorbild wird ein
atomministerium gegründet Aufgabe die
Förderung und Entwicklung von
Kernenergie auf Staatskosten Ziel
billiger Atomstrom die Menschheit sollte
ihre Kräfte darauf konzentrieren die
Atomkraft für die wissenschaftliche und
für die wirtschaftliche Nutzung zu
erschließen
wenn man sich die Atomwirtschaft anguckt
da ist es ein ganz starker staatlicher
Eingriff von Anfang an gewesen also
diese Forschungsreaktoren das sind Stahl
es wird diesen staatlich finanziert die
ist unklar wo wir stehen würden wenn die
erneuerbaren Energien seit den 60er
Jahren die gleiche Förderung erhalten
hätten die der turmwirtschaft behalten
hat
seither versucht die Politik unter dem
Stichwort Energiewende Deutschlands
Strom und Energiesektor zu regeln raus
aus der Kernenergie künftig keine Kohle
weniger Gas experten kritisieren bislang
war regierungshandel nicht wirklich voll
auf erneuerbare Energien ausgelegt wir
fangen immer an und hören dann auf
Beispiel Energiewende Ausbau der
Solarenergie der Windenergie da war
Deutschland mal führend dann haben wir
wieder 100.000 Arbeitsplätze vernichtet
die dann nach China entsprechend
exportiert und ausgelagert wurden und
gerade in den letzten zehn Jahren sind
da wirklich massive Fehler gemacht
worden
Arbeitsplätze die schaffen sie bei cm
blue momentan fertigen Sie 50
batterieblöcke am Tag nächstes Jahr
sollen es schon 200 sein die Ausbaupläne
sind abgeschlossen die Nachfrage im In-
und Ausland ist groß das politische
Interesse hierzulande eher verhalten
ausgeprägt im batteriebereich sind wir
Entwicklungsland was die Technologien
anbelangt da tut sich einiges und das
sollten wir jetzt wirklich auch
versuchen dass diese Pflänzchen groß
werden damit wir dann auch hier gegen
Player wie China dann zum Beispiel am
Ende dann bestehen können und so findet
die Revolution in Sachen
Flüssigkeitsstrom speichern Unterfranken
noch unbeachtet der deutschen
politischen Akteure statt übrigens zehn
blue wird künftig auch in den USA
produzieren staatliches Interesse und
Unterstützung sind dort wesentlich
ausgeprägter als hierzulande